قال تمكن عضو لجنه القوات المسلحه في مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي ان هناك حاجه الى تفسير
منطقي لقرار اداره بايدن وهو الثاني من
نوعه هذا الشهر المتعلق بارسال اسلحه الى
اسرائيل واوضح ان تجاوز الكونجرس الذي
يطلع بدور حاسم في قضايا الحرب والسلم
يعني ابقاء الشعب الامريكي في ظلام واضاف
انه يجب ان يكون للكونجرس رؤيه شامله بشان
الاسلحه التي يتم نقلها الى اي دوله
اخرى معنا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره عبد
الفتاح فايد عبد الفتاح اذا هي المره
الثانيه التي يقر فيها بلينكن صفقه لبيع
الاسلحه لاسرائيل
متجاوزا الكونجرس نرى الان موقف لتم كين
اجمل لنا ردود الافعال بهذا
الخصوص بالفعل وسيله هي المره الثانيه
وايضا ما يمكن ان نلاحظه في هذه المره هو
اللغه شديده اللهجه التي يستخدمها اعضاء
الكونجرس كما قال تيم كين هذه المره حيث
وصف ما يجري بانه ابقاء الشعب الامريكي في
الظلام كما قال بمعنى ان الاداره
الامريكيه تتجاوز حتى المؤسسات التشريعيه
الامريكيه في دعمها لاسرائيل وتزويدها
بهذه الاسلحه والذخائر ف
الدقه ايضا تحدث عن ان هذا الامر ليس له
تفسير منطقي بمعنى ان ما ورد في خطاب وفي
رساله وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني
بلينكن الى الكونجرس لم يكن مقنعا بالنسبه
له حيث اشار في رسالته التي ارسلها في
الساعات الاخيره وربما الدقائق الاخيره من
اخر يوم عمل في الاسبوع وهي يوم امس
الجمعه بان الامر عاجل
وحاله طوارئ تستدعي ارسال هذه الاسلحه في
نفس اليوم الذي بعث فيه برسالته الى
الكونجرس الامريكي وبالمناسبه ايضا في
المره الاولى التي كانت في التاسع من
ديسمبر من هذا الشهر ايضا ارسل الخطاب
ايضا في الساعه الاخيره من يوم الجمعه
ايضا وقبل بدايه عطله نهايه الاسبوع والان
هناك عطله نهايه الاسبوع وايضا عطله راس
السنه الميلاديه وبالتالي يتم ارسال
الخطاب في الساعات الاخيره من ايام العمل
في الاسبوع وعلى اساس ان هذا امر طارئ
وملح وان ضرورات الامن القومي الامريكي
وايضا الالتزام الامريكي بالدفاع عن امن
اسرائيل وحمايه امن اسرائيل تتطلب ارسال
هذه الذخائر بشكل عجيل طبعا وسيله عدم
ارسال هذه الموافقات الى الكونجرس ليس
معناه ان الكونجرس يقف ضد ارسال هذه
الطلبات او ان الكونجرس يمانع في دعم
اسرائيل على العكس من ذلك نحن تابعنا
الكونجرس عندما وجه اللوم الى النائبه في
الك كونجرس من اصول فلسطينيه رشيده طليب
لمجرد انها طالبت بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار
ودافعت عن غزه
وهاجمت ما تعتبره عدوانا اسرائيليا على
قطاع غزه ووجه الى اللوم باغلبيه كبيره
234 عضوا من كونجرس وجهوا اللوم الى رشيد
طلم من بينهم 22 عضوا من حزبها الحزب
الديمقراطي لكن الجديد هذه المره وسيله في
الحقيقه هو اولا تململ الكونجرس من الدعم
المفتوح من جانب اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن لاسرائيل قبل ذلك كان هناك مقال ل
السيناتور بيرني ساندرز في نيويورك تايمز
وايضا في رساله الى الكونجرس وطالب بوقف
ما اسمه شيك على بياض لاسرائيل وطلب بان
يتم ربط المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه
لاسرائيل بتغيير في سياستها على الارض
وتوقفها عن ارتكاب انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان
في غزه نعم اشكرك جزيل الشكر عبد الفتاح
فاهد مراسلنا من من واشنطن